Ich fand es wirklich lustig.
Die neue Sorte ist B.S.
Rund um die Uhr.
Ich fand das ziemlich gut.
An die Person, die gerade Sabinas Beitrag, How to Do Your Own Research, kommentiert hat.
Die kurze Geschichte, warum Menschen Bitch wollen.
Die Leute, die im Intro gute Absichten gelesen haben, haben sich geirrt.
In meinem abgeschnittenen Satz hier geht es um die Tatsache, dass wir viele Leute auf dem Kanal haben, die angeschrien werden, weil sie ihre eigenen Nachforschungen anstellen.
Und am Anfang von Sabinas Video spricht sie darüber, dass gute Vorsätze schief gelaufen sind, weil es sehr lange dauert, eine Abschlussarbeit zu schreiben und ähnliche Dinge.
Was ich im Folgenden über ihre Bemühungen gesagt habe, ist nur, dass sie versucht, den Leuten einen Rahmen zu geben, wegen all der akademischen Lügen, die da vor sich gehen.
Und das ist ihr Vektor.
Sie kommt aus der Wissenschaft.
Also, du weißt schon, nimm es oder lass es.
Ich dachte nur, es ist konfliktlösungsorientiert, also wollte ich es dabei belassen, damit die Leute es versuchen können.
Nein, es muss interessant sein.
Also allerlei interessante Dinge mit diesem Briefing durch einen Atomchef.
Chemisch.
Warte einen Moment.
Okay.
Da haben wir's.
Nukleare, chemische und biologische Schutztruppen der Streitkräfte, der Russischen Föderation, Generalleutnant und der USA militärische biologische Aktivität.
Nun, um auf all das einzugehen, wie wir bereits festgestellt haben, haben die USA militärische biologische Aktivitäten stellen für viele Nationen auf der ganzen Welt eine Sicherheitsbedrohung dar, obwohl die erklärten Ziele der USA Programme dienen der Überwachung von Krankheitsfällen und der Unterstützung von Entwicklungsländern.
Tatsächlich sehen wir, dass das Pentagon unter Umgehung der internationalen Verpflichtungen im Rahmen des TWC unkontrollierte Forschungsarbeiten mit doppeltem Verwendungszweck durchführt.
Also, was ich jetzt tun werde, ist, Ihre Aufmerksamkeit woanders zu lenken, was einige Leute überraschen könnte, aber hier unten steht, dass dies ein wichtiger Teil des etablierten elektronischen integrierten Krankheitsüberwachungssystems des Pentagon ist.
Wenn Sie noch nie auf meinem Kanal waren, spreche ich über elektronische Kriegsführung auf der Ebene des sogenannten Wide Body Area-Netzwerks.
Und ohne in ein riesiges Layout zu geraten.
Im Wesentlichen beobachten wir Menschen seit 2012 durch EEG mit einer sogenannten netzzentrierten Kriegsführung.
Netzzentrierte Kriegsführung nutzt alle Frequenzen im Körper, also wie du dich bewegst, wenn du dich bewegst.
Und dann verwenden wir wirklich fortschrittliche Mathematik mit etwas, das man Biophysik und Optoelektronik nennt, um Veränderungen an Ihrem Körper vorzunehmen, indem wir die Elektrizität nutzen, die Ihr Körper von Natur aus hat, und die Luftmoleküle um Ihren Körper herum.
Wenn ich Bioelektrizität sage, wissen die meisten Menschen nicht, dass wir an synthetischer Biologie gearbeitet haben und Ihren bioelektrischen Code elektrisch hacken und fracken.
Und der Grund, warum die meisten Leute nicht wissen, wovon ich spreche, ist, dass sie nicht wissen, dass unsere Elektroingenieure in Tripolis hier die neuen biomedizinischen Ingenieure sind.
Und das liegt auch daran, dass wir mit dem Tripolis ein ausgedehntes Netzwerk an Körperregionen haben, mit Biosensoren, die sich unter der Haut befinden.
Und diese Biosensoren bestehen aus dir, ihrer DNA und ihren Derivaten, sie sind aus dir gemacht.
Sie berichten an ein sogenanntes globales Informationsnetz, Super Net Nip oder Net.
Es gibt das Backend unseres sehr, sehr geheimen Informationssystems des Verteidigungsministeriums.
Wenn ich also die Behauptung aufstelle, dass dein Hintern an der Wolke hängt, dann liegt das daran, dass dein Hintern an der Wolke hängt, Punkt.
Es ist ein globales internationales System.
Von Sensoren.
Und dafür wiederum, weil die neuen Leute sagen, was?
Aber wie bekommen sie es in uns hinein?
Nun, Sie haben seit 1995 Body Area Networks.
Nochmals, das ist Ihr großes Body-Area-Network mit wem ich Tripolis und jetzt sind sie Biomediziningenieure, weil niemand ihnen all diese 70 Jahre elektronische Kriegsführung erzählt hat, in denen Sie mathematisch gesehen ein Körper in einer Killbox sind, für etwas, das man netzzentrierte Kriegsführung nennt.
Nun, das ist unmöglich.
Nein, Sie haben einen digitalen Zwilling in einem Computermodell und sie schnappen sich einfach das Modell am Backend des DSN, das alle auf der ganzen Welt hat.
Es gibt kein Dark Web, es gibt keine Privatsphäre.
Das ist alles Blödsinn.
Und wenn Sie das nicht wissen, liegt das daran, dass Sie nie für die NSA gearbeitet haben.
Ich übrigens auch nicht.
Ich habe 2014 hier bei Computer Weekly für einen Anbieter, einen Internetdienstanbieter, gearbeitet.
Ich habe das immer noch auf dem Kanal und lese es vor, weil es ein sehr angespannter Artikel ist.
Tötung im Netzwerk.
Der Mechanismus der netzzentrierten Kriegsführung lässt vermuten, dass das Vereinigte Königreich Die Verbindung hat die USA nicht erleichtert.
Drohnenangriffe sind absurd direkt von Internetdienstanbietern.
Und dann habe ich während der gesamten Aufnahme etwa 45 Minuten gebraucht, um den gesamten Artikel zu lesen.
Sie verstehen also, dass die netzzentrierte Kriegsführung Ihren Körper, Ihr Netzwerk jagt, weil wir nach Sensoren suchen, die sich in Ihnen befinden.
Unsere Biosensoren bestehen aus Ihrem Gewebe, seiner DNA und einem Lichtderivat.
Sie gibt es schon sehr lange.
Sie sind keine Biowaffe.
Wir verwenden sie für viele verschiedene Dinge.
Es ist eine unechte biochemische Umwandlung.
Wenn ich biochemisch sage, meine ich das auch.
Und ich sage, wenn du dein Mittagessen isst, kommt es nicht so hinten raus, wie es in deinem Mund war.
Der Körper ist elektrisch.
Sie lassen die Leute nicht darüber reden.
Sie haben die volle Kontrolle über diesen Körperteil.
Aus diesem Grund denken Energiearbeiter, sie würden ihr Kreislaufsystem abbauen.
Chakren sind einfach Knotenpunkte, an denen das Blut durch Ihre Venen und Arterien fließt.
Es ist ein gewisser Druck.
Das ist alles was sie sind.
Alle anderen da draußen, denen erlaubt wurde, mit New Age, Spiritualität und Bewusstsein aus den Fugen zu geraten, das war alles beabsichtigt, um Sie von der Einfachheit Ihrer eigenen menschlichen Anatomie fernzuhalten.
Alle sind sich einig, dass das Herz elektrisch ist.
Du starrst auf das toroidale Feld, das dich überall umgibt, genau hier auf diesem Bild.
Aber du darfst nicht darüber sprechen.
Du darfst es nicht mit intellektueller Schärfe oder akademischem Scharfsinn lernen.
Und das liegt daran, dass gerade Leute zur Arbeit gehen.
Sie passen Ihr körperliches, zentrales Nervensystem, Ihr Gewebe und alles in Ihrem Gehirngewebe, Ihrem Muskelgewebe und Ihren Hormonen an, weil Ihr Biofeld ein Körperteil ist.
Das ist ein Körperteil.
Es ist ein elektrischer Körperteil, der jede Zelle in Ihrem Körper über Ihr gesamtes Lymphgewebe, Ihr Gefäßsystem, Ihre Venen und Arterien beeinflusst.
Indem sie die Leute also unwissend halten, melden sie sich buchstäblich einfach an.
Und in der I Tripolis 8 oder 2.15 kann man sehen, dass da der Körperteil ist und all die elektrischen Felder, die damit einhergehen.
Nun, das ist furchtbar.
Ja, das verstehe ich.
Aber es wird noch schlimmer, weil die Biosensoren alle unterschiedlich sind.
Sie sind nicht alle gleich.
Sie sind nicht gleich gebaut.
Und die Sensoren, die wir verwenden, haben wir überall in der Luft, überall um Menschen herum.
Schlimmer noch, jedes Mal, wenn ich versuche, das den Leuten zu erklären, wie Sie auf meinem kleinen Umweg von 4 bis 5 Minuten sehen können, muss ich das Gehirn auffrischen, dass dies Ihr Körper genau hier ist.
Es wird 2.1, 5.6 sein.
Die Sensoren selbst sind acht oder 2.1, 5.4, und dann haben sie kleine Sensornetzwerke nur für ihre kleinen Sensorzellen.
Und das sind acht oder 2,1, 5,5.
Und wir haben eine Menge Computer-Routing-Protokolle, die direkt durch die Haut gehen.
Und deshalb sind Ihre neuen Ärzte das erste Tripolis der Biowissenschaften, denn das, was ich Ihnen zeige, ist drahtloses Tissue Engineering, das unter etwas fällt, das man Biomedizin nennt.
Ingenieurwesen.
Um den Menschen zu helfen, all das zu verstehen, musste ich ihnen auch erklären, dass in den neuen 60 Jahren die drahtlose Chirurgie bevorsteht.
Dieser Artikel, den ich Ihnen zeige, stammt aus dem Jahr 2021 aus der Fernchirurgie mit VR, XR, Ambient Air.
Das sind alles deine Augmented Reality.
Und jeder sagt: Nun, das ist unmöglich.
Ja, das liegt daran, dass du nicht weißt, dass sie sich in diesen Körperteil einloggen, um deine Zellen zu verändern.
Also, wenn ich dir sage, dass die Drohne über dein Haus fliegt und die Änderung vornimmt, was denkst du?
Offensichtlich drehe ich meinen Deckel um.
Ich muss verrückt sein.
Und dann kommen die Energiearbeiter, von denen ich intellektuelle Rechenschaftspflicht verlangt habe.
Und damit waren sie nicht zufrieden.
Sie wollen an das glauben, woran sie glauben wollen.
Sie wollen nicht, dass ihnen gesagt wird, dass dies ein Körperteil ist und dass wir dafür wissenschaftliche Erkenntnisse haben.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Sie sprechen mit Außerirdischen.
Sie sprechen mit ihren Geistführern.
Und ich sagte, Leute, Geistführer brauchen keine Satelliten.
Für diese speziellen Leute war es egal.
Und dann freuten sich andere Leute, als sie herausfanden, dass es einfach ein Körperteil war und dass sie dann hoffentlich etwas damit anfangen konnten.
Und dann sind wir direkt in die Killbox gerannt.
Für die heutigen Zwecke, wenn Sie sich all dessen nicht bewusst sind, nun, wissen Sie, wenn Sie immer noch nicht verstehen, warum das ein Problem ist, dann liegt es daran, dass ein Haufen Leute jetzt, heute, arbeiten werden, sich bei Ihnen ein- und ausloggen und Ihr elektrisches Körperteil an eine andere Firma übergeben.
Das wird zum Kotzen.
Das ist okay.
Wir werden es durchstehen.
Lassen Sie uns also über Sprengsätze sprechen.
Das elektronische integrierte Krankheitsüberwachungssystem.
Zuallererst werden wir hier nachforschen und uns die typische Architektur eines integrierten Systems zur elektronischen Überwachung von Krankheiten besorgen, Juni 2012.
Inzwischen wurde das elektronische integrierte Krankheitsüberwachungssystem eingesetzt, um die Überwachung und Prävention gefährlicher Krankheiten zu stärken und zu unterstützen.
Dabei wurde ein einheitliches Gesundheitskonzept entwickelt, das tierärztliche und humane Überwachung, passive und aktive Ansätze sowie fallbasierte Aufzeichnungen, einschließlich krankheitsspezifischer klinischer Daten, integriert.
Also, als ich hierher ging, um mir die Bilder anzusehen, was sehe ich hier?
Datenbankserver und Body-Area-Netzwerke.
Nun, das ergibt Sinn.
Warum?
Warum ist das sinnvoll?
Weil wir Biosensoren kommerziell einsetzen.
Entschuldigen Sie mich.
Seit 2005 und das Wide Body Area Network.
Oh, verdammt noch mal, lass mich in Ruhe.
Und das Body Area Network seit 1995.
Also haben wir die Körper aller beobachtet, wie Ruanda, du weißt schon, Aerosol.
Und dann beobachte die Biosensoren auf dem Pfeil.
2.15.5, Endpunkt vier Individualisierte Gremien nach Punkt sechs.
Okay, wir haben also Benachrichtigungen, Berichte, Geokarten, wir wissen, wohin Sie sich bewegen usw.
usw..
2012.
Okay.
In Ordnung.
Das ist hilfreich.
Richtig.
Verteilungs- und prozedurale Messung.
Das ist etwas anderes.
Los geht's.
H Und da ich eine Hybrid-Cloud nur für die Wissenschaft cloud.
Ein bisschen wie das Kommunikationssystem für medizinische Implantate auf den engen Frequenzbändern für Industrie, Wissenschaft und Medizin.
Auf diese Weise ist es einfacher, Geschäfte zu machen.
Es ist einfacher, es zu schützen.
Sie können alles an einem Ort aufbewahren, oder?
Die Helix Nebula Science Cloud hat eine Hybrid-Cloud-Plattform entwickelt, die kommerzielle Cloud-Dienstleister und Forschungsorganisationen intern miteinander verbindet.
Das bedeutet proprietäre IT.
Ressourcen, mehr Sicherheitsleute über die GI und das Netzwerk.
Die Plattform bietet Datenverwaltungsfunktionen mit transparenten Daten.
Access for Applications kann ohne Änderungen auf beiden Seiten der Hybrid Cloud und mit Rechendiensten bereitgestellt werden, auf die über Education und ELIXIR, Federated Identity and Access Management Systems, zugegriffen werden kann.
Erinnerst du dich, was ich über die Web-Logins auf dem ACE-Symposium gesagt habe?
Es sind Web-Logins.
Sie gehen auf eine Website, auf der wir gerade sind, nicht unbedingt ResearchGate.
Ich meine einfach jedes Webportal.
Das heißt, ich gebe meine Anmeldedaten ein und melde mich in Ihrem Körper für meinen Testtest an, der dann ein Signal an ein Opt-In-Array sendet und die Änderung mit Ihrem intelligenten Stromnetz direkt in der Umgebung und den allgegenwärtigen Rechenluftmolekülen vornimmt.
Als Wissenschaftler oder als Lernender komme ich also nicht einfach rein und logge mich ein.
Und hier vergleiche ich Hochenergiephysik, Astronomie, Biowissenschaften, Photoneneutronenwissenschaften, alle Rechen- und Speichernetzwerkkonnektivität und Federated Identity Management.
Die Beschaffungs-Cloud-Dienste, die in Beschaffer, interne Ressourcen und öffentlich finanzierte Infrastruktur integriert sind, bieten eine Hybridplattform in vier verschiedenen Phasen, wie in Abbildung dargestellt.
zwei für eine Phase der Bedarfsermittlung, die der Ausschreibungsphase entspricht.
Die Anbieter treten in drei Forschungs- und Entwicklungsphasen ein: Design, Prototyp und Pilotprojekt, von denen jede über einen Zeitraum von drei Jahren wettbewerbsfähig ist.
Korrekt.
Und dann kann es jeder benutzen.
Das ist im Jahr 2012 und es sieht aus wie ein Update hier.
2018.
Wir haben den richtigen.
Entschuldigung, das ist 2018.
Ja.
Und das Originalzeug.
Nein, es tut mir leid.
Januar 2019.
Oh, gut, gut.
Wir haben aktualisiert.
Mit anderen Worten, sie haben die Möglichkeit, ein Login zu verteilen.
Dies sind 2018, 2019 und der Cloud-Prototyp mit Hybrid Cloud April 2017.
Okay.
Entwurfsphase, die Entwurfsphase des H.
Und so begann Cloud während der Ausschreibungszeremonie.
In dieser Phase wurden 15% des im Februar 2017 bereitgestellten Budgets für das Projekt bereitgestellt.
Die vier Konsortien lieferten ihre Entwürfe, darunter Architektur und technisches Design der Komponenten.
Zusammen mit den Stückkosten.
Die in Frage kommenden Auftragnehmer reichten ihre Angebote für die Prototypenphase Anfang März ein, und das H and Cloud Evaluation Committee bewertete die Angebote und wählte die drei vielversprechendsten aus.
Die drei Gewinnerkonsortien Moving to the H in Cyclo-Prototypenphase sind in Abbildung 4 dargestellt.
Die Bekanntgabe erfolgte am 3.
April 2017 im Rahmen der Preisverleihung am CERN in Genf, Schweiz.
Die unterirdische Wartung oder wie sie von diesem riesigen elektromagnetischen Feld erfuhren, also haben wir schon früher darüber gesprochen.
Auftragnehmer zwei ist IBM.
Auftragnehmer eins sieht aus wie zwei Systeme waren sicher Siphon es und Divya unsere Altersgruppe T Systeme Exascale und sechs als Q sind Auftragnehmer drei und Auftragnehmer vier Indra HP Evgenia und Erfolg.
F: Okay, lassen Sie uns sehen, wie viel mehr davon ich Ihren mobilen Systemen zeigen möchte und wie sie sich hin und her bewegen werden?
Funktionstests, Niederfrequenzarrays, die ersten einer neuen Art von Teleskop, das eine Reihe einfacher Rundstrahlantennen verwendet, im Gegensatz zu einer Schüssel, die für die mechanische Signalverarbeitung bestimmt ist.
Die von den Antennen erhaltenen elektronischen Signale werden digitalisiert und an einen zentralen digitalen Prozessor übertragen.
Die Antennen sind einfach genug, aber es gibt eine große Anzahl von ihnen, etwa 7000 im vollen Tieffall.
Unser Design-Niederfrequenzarray.
Das Hauptziel des Anwendungsfalls mit geringem Nutzwert besteht darin, verstreute Speicher- und Rechenressourcen zu testen und anschließend in Produktion umzuwandeln, die über ganz Europa verteilt sind.
Der Helix Nebula Science Club bietet diese Möglichkeit aufgrund der Verfügbarkeit einer Hochgeschwindigkeits-Netzwerkverbindung der G- und Cloud-Infrastruktur, die sehr leistungsfähig ist.
Ich möchte sichergehen, dass ich angemessen bin und wie ich das sage.
Also werde ich es genau so sprechen, wie es ist.
Ja.
Okay.
Wie nennen Sie die F-Infrastruktur?
Wer?
Muslim ist diesbezüglich ein Vollidiot.
Diese Akronyme Virtuelles Routing und Forwarding.
Oh.
Oh oh, ist das erledigt.
Oh Gott.
Okay.
Virtual Routing and Forwarding ist eine IP-IP-basierte Computernetzwerktechnologie, die die gleichzeitige Koexistenz mehrerer virtueller Router als Instanzen oder virtuelle Routerinstanzen innerhalb desselben Routers ermöglicht.
Willkommen bei Quantum.
Ja.
Lieblich.
Und das Preismodell?
Jep.
Die Photonen-Neutronenwissenschaft ist ein Krist für die serielle Femtosekunden-Kristallographie.
Das Crystal-Framework wird für die Technik der seriellen Femtosekunden-Kristallographie SFX verwendet und umfasst Programme zur Datenverarbeitung, Simulation und Visualisierung.
Crystal als Teil eines komplexen, nicht verteilbaren, nicht verteilbaren Software-Stack-Security-Programms, das von Hochschulen, Gartensicherheits- und gemeinnützigen Organisationen kostenlos genutzt werden kann.
Das Crystal Framework wird zunehmend an verschiedenen Synchrotronen eingesetzt, um Daten aus der seriellen Femtosekunden-Röntgenkristallographie zu analysieren.
Die Art dieser Experimente macht eine cloudbasierte verteilte Pipeline besonders attraktiv, da das Framework große Rechenressourcen mit einstellbaren Daten oder einstellbaren Anforderungen voll ausnutzen kann, sodass diese Arrays und Antennen auf Ihre DNA abgestimmt werden können.